hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played on Ches
comm it's a blitz game between Gahan mg
who is a 23 year old the freedom master
from Bangalore India and Grand Master
Robert has who I believe needs no
introduction it's it's a really exciting
game I'm sure gonna enjoy it a very
short one but I also would like to
mention once again that today is the
last day for you to be a part of the
subscribers video so if you haven't sent
any photos or videos you still have a
chance today because tomorrow we're
gonna pile everything up and we're gonna
start editing the subscribers video I
just wanted to share that with you and
if you've been using any pro I mean any
clients like VTrans for something that
has expiring links please resend it
again but if I run into such emails I
will also mention I will reply to your
email saying that you know the link has
expired and you should send it or once
again so sorry about that but we will
only be piling everything up now
tomorrow and also one other thing as you
can see in the corner above the board in
the left corner the leaches team battle
starts today at 8 p.m. at Central
European Time and well we're gonna do a
livestream it's gonna be - two hours of
extreme battles and yawn almighty and
myself will be doing some some
commenting and we'll be showcasing your
games so you when you will be playing
against other teams your your game will
most likely come up and then we're gonna
comment on it and enjoy it well everyone
will hopefully enjoy it so that's what I
wanted to say the links to join our team
will be in the description below first
link will be a link where you can join
our team and second link will be a link
to that elite chess team battle where
you can join the actually join the
tournament so sorry about a longer
introduction but I just needed to put it
out there now that being said let's
check out the game gihan mg opens with E
4 and Robert has goes for d6 so the
Pearce is on the board we have d4 and
Knight to f6 going after the e4 pawn
Gahan defended with Knight to c3 and c6
now preparing
a further expansion on the queenside we
have F 4 and now Queen to a5 bringing
the Queen a bit too early perhaps but
it's it has been played before since the
night is now pinned you're threatening
to capture on e4 why to defense the e4
pawn and now here e5 is the main and
main idea but his goes for a much rarer
move which is d5 he invites a 5 so God
replies with e5 and we have Knight to e4
now with a double attack on the night
here so Gahan decides it's time to get
rid of the bishop prepare we're gonna
give it up captures captures now the e
pawn it's doubled and we're just gonna
attack at Queen e2 so threatening just
to capture the point here and while it
is possible to defend it with the bishop
the 5 main idea is Knights to a6 the
since you want White's to capture here
you wanna play g6 use the DF 5 square to
kick away the Queen and you want to pile
up on the c2 pawn with Knights to be 4
so that's the idea for black white goes
for it with Queen captures on e4 and now
black continues with with the
development the g6 so the the pawn
Center is Center is nicely controlled
Bishop to a5 is coming and here there
are a few moves that were played in this
position Queen e2 is a known move Knight
to f3 so no move but this is a Bishop to
b2 it's a new move in the position and
it is as a move 10 that we have a
completely new game so of course the
Hesse takes this opportunity to bring
his Bishop into the game without wasting
time so Bishop f5 attacks the Queen
Queen back to e 2 and now comes nice the
b4 and although the bishop here looks
like a looks like a aggressive idea
I developed the Bishop prepares a
queenside castle perhaps there are
actually no good
discoveries here since the Queen can
just capture on both squares but ok
Knights the B form is now going after
the siege upon and here we have just
castles Queen side and this is already a
very shaky position for white probably
White was for White was hoping for
Knight captures on a2 with check after
which King Tubby one can we play with a
double attack on the night and now you
either trade and then this Bishop gets a
nice active square or you go back Knight
to be for rule
see one you defend the pawn and now you
continue playing the game as the black
King is also still in the center of the
board however has has had a different
idea he goes for Bishop captures and c2
and now what do you play here if you
move the rook since the rook is under
attack it's not really good if you move
it to f1 then Bishop to d3 will just win
material so if you play rook to e1
Bishop d3 comes just the same and after
you move the Queen now blackhole Castle
queenside and it's just disgusting
position for for white white really has
no moves here and black can just do
whatever black wants so now this will be
completely winning for black so instead
after Bishop captures on c2 white played
a3 now pushing the knight back so then
the bishop can be captured but has gets
rid of the the threats of which tempo so
he plays Bishop to d3 this comes with an
attack on the Queen and now you don't
have a capture Sun before saying that
okay now we're just gonna trade Queens
and I grab your piece because Queen a1
check Knight B 1 and Queen captures and
B 1 will be made so not possible here
gihan played queen to f3 saying okay I'm
attacking your Bishop and also your
knight so what are you going to play
here so well feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning idea
for Hess well I'll give you a couple of
seconds it's also the reason why we are
showing this video as it's just just a
wonderful idea
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on supporting the
greatest Queen sacrifice of 2020 so far
and for those who if you just want to
enjoy a show its Queen to a4 quinta a
form seems like a weird idea putting the
Queen in front of the night but the
point is you want to take away the a2
square from whites night if white knight
doesn't have access to the a2 squared
then Knights the a2 will be made it
comes with check and the bishop is
covering the light squares in front of
the King so
Queeny Queeny for just does a beautiful
job getting rid of the night from a2 and
you don't really have an option here you
can you cannot not capture the Queen
because queen to c2 is mate
so anything you play here you're getting
checkmate it if you capture here then
it's Queen to c2 mate if you capture on
a4 then we
already mentioned night the a to check
is made because the bishop covers the
light squares in front of the White King
and lastly but not leastly Queen
captures and III seems like an idea
since you're now ready to capture here
but night captures and III comes with
check and then after you move the King
just Queen b3 threatens mate you will be
able to survive mate but then just
Knight f2 will win even more material
after you have already won the Queen so
of course completely winning for black
so this is in fact how the game ended
after this Queen to have to remove has
played Queen to a4 and it was in this
position that gahan mg resigned the game
and this beautiful 14 move game was
created so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it once again at today is the
last day to join the subscribers video
and do join us today in our elite chess
team battle efforts to battle the other
teams the two of the links you need will
be in the description below one to join
the team and want to join the tournament
so that's what I wanted to mention I
would like to thank you look back to
normative Harold hotter Jurgen kun I
feel like no c'mon and Stefan my mother
Swati for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot that really appreciated
more we have contributed but my
interface allows only 4 5 5 thank you
for video but we will be making more
videos soon no worries
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some other interesting games such as
this one if if if they happen still
preparing the amorphous saga end we will
have our livestream today two hours be
there a 8 p.m. Central European Time you
know my T and myself we will do our best
to entertain you guys so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day